Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're here.
It seems like there's
so much going on right now.
Prince Harry's new book
came out today.
The horror movie "M3GAN"
is a hit at the box office.
Tonight's Mega Millions jackpot
was over $1.1 billion.
And Papa John's just unveiled
these new doughy snack balls
called Papa Bites.
[ Laughter ]
There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
♪♪
First up, Prince Harry.
Today, his new book called
"SPARE" hit shelves,
and it's full of details about
his life, his relationships,
and his exit
from the royal family.
Long story short, everything
changed when he married...
"M3GAN."
The --
[ Laughter ]
The horror movie is doing great
at the box office,
bringing in over $30 million.
It's made so much money,
the producers feel like
they won...
the lottery.
Tonight's Mega Millions jackpot
was one of the biggest
of all time, over $1.1 billion.
Wow. That's a lot of...
dough.
Papa John's uses it
to make their new snack
called Papa Bites,
but don't eat too many --
you only have one heart.
You don't have a..."SPARE."
The book talks about
how Harry didn't get along
with his brother,
his stepmother, or his...
Papa.
Seriously, don't overdo it
on those little bites.
They're so high in calories,
they could....
kill you.
"M3GAN" is a terrifying doll,
kinda like Annabelle
or even Chucky, the...
redhead.
Harry didn't have just
one reason to leave England.
It was more like...a billion.
And that's -- that's enough
money to live like a...
prince.
Harry is speaking out against
his powerful family.
And you've got to admit,
that takes...
balls.
These treats might be
too much for some people,
but stoners are
looking at them like...
jackpot!
In conclusion...
so much to tell...
Will it sell?
What's that smell?
Run like hell.
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
Oh, my goodness.
Thank you, everybody.
Everyone is talking about this.
President Biden's lawyers
were cleaning out
one of his old offices
from before he was president.
And you're not gonna
believe this,
but they found that Biden
had 10 classified documents.
[ Audience oohs ]
The documents found were from
Biden's time as vice president.
Today, Obama was like,
"Nothing to worry about.
If Joe had access,
it wasn't important.
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry about it."
Yep, Biden was shocked and said
he had no idea
how the documents got there.
Then Hunter Biden was like,
"Okay, so don't get mad..."
[ Laughter ]
Of course,
former President Trump
wasted no time weighing in.
He got on his social-media
platform and posted,
"When is the FBI going to raid
the many homes of Joe Biden,
perhaps even the White House?"
Good point.
It -- It would be suspicious
if classified documents
were found at the White House.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of the White House,
the Biden administration
is considering a nationwide ban
on gas stoves,
which has been linked
to health problems.
Today, Americans were like,
"Better play it safe and order
a Baconator from Door Dash."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, gas stoves
could be banned soon.
The best way to heat something
up will be to open three apps
on your iPhone at once
then use it as a hot plate.
Tssss!
Get that sear you want.
That's right --
gas stoves are a problem,
but somehow deep-frying a turkey
is still perfectly legal.
I don't know.
And on your back porch, no less.
Guys, the horror movie "M3GAN"
is the biggest new movie
out in theaters.
In fact, it's such a huge hit,
they're already
working on a sequel.
Yeah. Take a look
at the trailer I just saw.
-The surprise hit of the year
is "M3GAN."
And coming next year, be sure to
catch the heart-stopping sequel,
"M2GAN" -- or "M3GAN 2."
Or is it "M23GAN"?
"M32-GAN." "M2G3N."
"2GM3N."
Eh, screw it!
Go see "Murder Doll 2."
COM1N9...
Oh, come on!
-Interesting.
[ Applause ]
Well, switching gears,
I read that Babies "R" Us,
which went out of business
in 2018,
is opening a new
flagship mall store,
which is crazy, because the mall
didn't even know it was
expecting a Babies "R" Us.
Classic story.
You think your family is done
having Babies "R" Us,
and then a few years later,
you're ready to try for more.
Well, listen to this.
A new study found that
eating healthier can increase
your chances of living longer.
[ Laughter ]
That's not all
they figured out, though.
Check out some of these
other new scientific findings.
First up, fire hot.
[ Laughter ]
Next, if you stay underwater
for too long, you could "drown."
And, finally...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meanwhile, I saw a new study
that said noise from a ship
can disrupt crabs
while they're trying to mate.
Or, as crabs call it,
getting yacht blocked.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, all sea life is
knocking on the bottom of boats
like, "Hey, we're trying
to make caviar here!"
Yeah, it's things like this
that can make a sea creature's
sex life flounder, you know?
[ Laughter ]
[ Steve groans ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
-More?
-One more.
-Okay. One more.
-Of course, when crabs do mate,
the most embarrassing part is
the next day when they have to
do the sideways walk of shame.
[ Laughter ]
That's it. Come on.
I had to do that one.
-Come on.
-That's never...
-No, yeah.
-Get this.
In London, for the first time
since the pandemic,
dozens of people rode the train
without pants
for the annual
No Trousers Tube Ride.
Yep, dozens of people rode
the train without pants,
or, as it's called in New York,
Tuesday.
Hey! There you go.
And finally, before we move on,
I'd like to take a moment
to thank some of our sponsors
for tonight's show.
They don't always fit
in commercial breaks,
and we want to make sure
that we mention all of them.
It's time
for "Tonight Show Sponsors."
-♪ Tonight Show Sponsors ♪
♪ Tonight Show Sponsors ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Kettle brand chips...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Sports.
Carnival Cruise...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally...
That's all
for "Tonight Show Sponsors."